♪ ♪
>> Jesse: DEMOCRATS GETTING
COLD HARD CASH TO KEEP THEIR
LOVED ONES SAFE WHILE LEAVING
YOUR NEIGHBORHOODS AT THE MERCY
OF DANGEROUS CRIMINALS.
DESPITE A BIG PUSH FROM
PRESIDENT BIDEN TO REFUND POLICE
DEPARTMENT, HOUSE DEMOCRATS ARE
DELAYING A PLAN TO DO JUST THAT.
AT THE SAME TIME, EVERY MEMBER
OF CONGRESS IS SET TO GET
$10,000 TO PUT IN SECURITY
SYSTEMS IN THEIR HOMES INCLUDING
$150 A MONTH JUST TO MAINTAIN
THEM.
IT GETS BETTER.
DEMOCRATS TRY TO RUN AWAY FROM
THE DEFINED MOVEMENT, ONE TOP
LEADER SAYS IT'S A LIE TO FALL
THEM OUT OVER IT.
>> THE NOTION THAT ANY OF OUR
FRONTLINE MEMBERS OR MEMBERS OF
THE HOUSE DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS
SUPPORT THESE DEFINING THE
POLICE IS JUST PART OF THE BIG
LIE THAT EXTREME REPUBLICANS
CONTINUE TO TELL ABOUT
EVERYTHING.
>> Jesse: ROSANNA, I AM SURE
YOU KNOW WE HAVE MINUTES AND
MINUTES OF TAPE OF THE SQUAD.
THEY CONSIDER THEM TO BE
FRONTLINE MEMBERS, HOUSE
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS, SAYING DEFUND
THE POLICE UNTIL A COUPLE MONTHS
AGO.
>> Rosanna: SO MANY PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN SAYING DEFUND THE
POLICE.
IN NEW YORK CITY, OUR PUBLIC
ADVOCATE WAS RUNNING FOR
GOVERNOR.
WE FIND OUT.
LEADING PROTESTS ALL OVER
NEW YORK WHICH HE SAID WASN'T
REALLY ABOUT DEFINING THE
POLICE.
IT WAS ABOUT APPROPRIATING IT
SOMEWHERE ELSE.
WE FIND OUT THAT HE LIVES ON A
MILITARY BASE.
FORT HAMILTON.
IT IS A GORGEOUS BASE.
I DIDN'T REALIZE.
15% OF THE MILITARY BASE
CIVILIANS CAN APPLY THE LIVE
THERE.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT.
YOU WON'T FIND IT ANZA LOW.
ANYWAY, HE LIVES THERE,
BEAUTIFUL TOWNHOUSE, SWEEPING
VIEWS OF THE VERRAZANO.
$14 HAIRCUTS.
WAIT A SECOND.
24-HOUR MILITARY SECURITY.
>> Jesse: THAT'S WHAT IT IS.
GERALDO, NOW YOU'RE SEEING THEM,
PEOPLE THEY DIDN'T WANT ANYONE
TO BE PROTECTED IN OUR CITIES,
CRIME-RIDDEN CITIES AND NOW THEY
GET TEN GRAND, TEN GRAND.
IT IS A LOT OF MOOLAH.
>> Geraldo: PUT ASIDE THE
SECURITY.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT THE HOUSE
HAS A BILL THAT WILL FUND
JURISDICTIONS TO HIRE COPS,
INVEST IN MENTAL HEALTH AND
IMPLEMENT VIOLENCE INTERVENTION.
THEY CAN'T PASS IT.
WHY CAN'T THEY PASS IT.
BECAUSE THE SQUAD FEELS THEY
NEED MORE PROTECTION AGAINST
POLICE BRUTALITY, MORE
LIMITATIONS ON COPS.
THEY'VE GOT TO ENSURE THAT THE
POLICE ARE EVENHANDED.
IT IS B.S. REALLY THEY ARE
REFUNDING COPS.
THEY ARE DEFUNDING BY INACTION.
I REALLY CRITICIZE IT.
DATA TALKS.
B.S. WALKS.
IF THEY REALLY WANT TO FUND THE
POLICE, THEM FUND THE POLICE.
NOT CONTINUE THIS NONSENSE.
>> Jesse: HE SAID DANA TALKS.
B.S. WALKS.
>> Dana: I WANT TO COMMENT.
I WANT TO SAY WHEN HE CAME
JEFFREY'S IS UP THERE IN HE'S
TALKING, ANYONE WHO SAYS
DEMOCRATS DOESN'T WANT TO FUND
THE POLICE, THAT'S THE BIG LIE.
USING THE WORST COMMUNICATORS IN
THE WORLD.
THEY HAVE THE BIG LIE BRANDON
ABOUT ELECTION FRAUD.
BUT NOW THEY HAVE MODEL THAT
COMPLETELY AND NOW EVERYTHING IS
IN BIG LIES WE HAVE ALREADY LOST
ON THAT ONE.
CONGRATULATIONS, NOT VERY SMART.
ALSO I'M SO MAD ABOUT THIS
BECAUSE ABIGAIL SPANBERGER,
MODERATE DEMOCRAT FROM VIRGINIA,
SHE WAS THE ONE WHO WAS ON THE
CONFERENCE CALL AFTER THE
ELECTION SAYING GUYS, WE HAVE A
SERIOUS PROBLEM.
WE HAVE TO DO SOMETHING.
NANCY PELOSI SAYS ABIGAIL,
PLEASE TRY TO GET THIS BILL
DONE.
SHE GETS IT ALL THE WAY TO THE
ONE-YARD LINE AND THEN THESE
OUTSIDE GROUPS LIKE THE
LEADERSHIP CONFERENCE ON THE --
LEADERSHIP CONFERENCE ON CIVIL
AND HUMAN RIGHTS, THEY MASSIVELY
SUPPORTED DEFUND THE POLICE.
THEY KILLED IT.
NOW GOOD LUCK TO THE DEMOCRATS
AND THEY ARE TRYING TO DO ALL
THIS FROM THE MINORITY BECAUSE
SOMEBODY LIKE ABIGAIL SPANBERGER
IN A VERY CLOSE RACE.
NANCY PELOSI GAVE HER A CHANCE
TO TRY TO FIX IT SO SHE COULD GO
HOME AND SAY THAT SHE DID
SOMETHING AND NOW THE SQUAD
KILLED IT.
>> Jesse: I THINK WE SHOULD
DRINK EVERY TIME DANA SAYS
ABIGAIL SPANBERGER.
>> Dana: WHY?
>> Jesse: YOU MENTION HER NAME
A LOT.
>> Greg: YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER
THAT TIME WHEN THEY WERE CRYING
FOR DEFUND THE POLICE.
AT A VERY VULNERABLE MOMENT IN
OUR COUNTRY.
IT WAS AN INDULGENCE BY LEADERS
OF THE MOB.
IT WAS A REALLY UGLY THING TO
HEAR YOUR POLITICIAN SAY YOU
KNOW WHAT, WE ARE WILLING TO
DESTROY CIVIL SOCIETY TO PLACATE
PEOPLE ON THE STREET.
THE TWITTERVERSE.
THIS WAS NOT ABOUT MAKING
SOCIETY BETTER.
HE WAS ABOUT A BUNCH OF PEOPLE
VIRTUE SIGNALING.
THE WORST THING A LEADER CAN DO
IS VIRTUE SIGNAL.
THAT'S ALL THE LEFT DOES NOW IS
VIRTUE SIGNAL.
I UNDERSTAND WHY THEY ARE
RUNNING FROM THIS NOW BECAUSE
IT'S KIND OF DISGUSTING.
IT'S REALLY SCUMMY WHAT HAPPENED
BUT IT DOES BOIL DOWN TO THE
INITIAL FACT IN THE FIRST TEASE.
WE AS AMERICANS ARE PAYING FOR
THE SECURITY WHICH THEY REFUSED
TO TAKE CARE OF OURS.
THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO BE SERVANTS
OF THE PEOPLE.
IT'S NOT SUPPOSED TO BE THE
REVERSE.
IT SHOWS WHY THEY GOT INTO THE
BUSINESS, THE POLITICS.
THEY COULD BE EXEMPT FROM THE
PUNISHMENT AND THE LAWS THAT
THEY ENACT ON US.
THINK ABOUT IT GLOBALLY.
THEY DON'T SUFFER CRIME BECAUSE
THEY ARE PROTECTED WITH
SECURITY.
THEY DON'T WEAR MASKS WE WERE
ALL WEARING MASKS.
THEY DON'T FLY COMMERCIAL.
THEY CAN RUN RED LIGHTS.
LORI LIGHTFOOT.
YOU HAVE A BIG LIBERAL NAME, YOU
HAVE A WOMAN WHO DIES IN THE
LAKE AND YOU'RE STILL IN
POLITICS.
YOU CAN GET AWAY WITH EVERYTHING
THAT WE CAN'T KNOW WE'VE GOT TO
PAY FOR.
I STILL SAY TAKE THE CRIMINALS
WHEN THEY GET RELEASED, PUT AN
ANKLE BRACELET ON THEM.
DROP THEM OFF WITHIN A SHORT
RADIUS OF THESE LEFTIST HOMES.
AND THEN BEEPING EVERY TIME THEY
LEAVE THE NEIGHBORHOOD.
THEY HAVE TO STAY IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD WHERE THE IDIOTS
MAKE THE RULES.
MOVABLE WILL LEARN THE
CONSEQUENCES.
>> Jesse: I LIKE THE IDEA.
>> Greg: ALVIN BRAGG STREET.
PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN RELEASED
TO NEW YORK.
HOW IS THAT --